I don't know why I split up do I know
where action sushi and smoke that's mine
hi this is me oh yeah was was really me
why would that happen but there are
something I was on
stay calm
dear this
it's what
I have no idea
I don't direct once the ball is steady
then he's just gonna make it was a
minute you do weird [ __ ] with mouth what
is he doing
what's accessibility would probably miss
at work who admitted that that why is
that than being uncomfortable
what are you doing with your face that's
so weird
so we have to remember to mistake okay
so we were a little bit towards them in
on aggressively
yeah they're not aggressive generally as
well Emily go with you and they start
she doesn't just keep walking like
string no just keep walking like you're
in charge not like you wanna you know
excellent it is
okay yeah because I could close be what
she wanted right now that's true
I don't really want to but she didn't
see me doing anything that's a county
watching this day like their church
these guys are curious they are not some
I'm going to know that's example good
butterfly effect
yeah I'm happy with that right yeah it's
just analyst impacts you know they look
frightening please wait for a little
towards us because they're curious
there's much difference that's not
amazing to do it's an element I'm Emily
now we never been Emily what's the
change or how do you know this change
other than to try just because the the
way that I'm looking at she's doing it
really just why did it change I would
guess it just to show you from
perspective like what a nice crunch look
give you more mode we think she's
fearless from other than she's [ __ ] but
she's but she's smart but maybe she's
just efficient
let's get that real first isolate this
is where I wanted us to go
oh absolutely yeah we're not in control
of this something [ __ ] up is gonna
happen here
these this chapter is called psychosis
it's just a security plan [ __ ]
that's our problem
hopefully probably not that some folks
are happy
yeah they make the molds but I kind of
liked that book because what would they
be a guidance turn huh
that's good that's the part of the game
that I told you my plate when Chris has
got his hand in that he put it down but
I shot actually oh [ __ ] so maybe if you
go to shoot himself you could still
watch yeah I get that probably it is a
city emergency yeah it's not that
something turned on that's good
I think this is quite sensible although
devote so much crap I think we've been
manipulated to go here is the thing
because like I was sitting there
watching them do it if he wanted to kill
them
well maybe he's would say maybe it's
hard to not you know rich timelines I
wasn't I'm showing right now is Mike
still doing a September but all we don't
know I feel like marks in a bad place we
could lose him soon
no no that's just my imagination
yeah but actually crazy frankly I expect
that you mister next I thinking that was
the established all right you've got
this you know something man you know
just era but the hallway oh all right
that was a mistake
I didn't have a choice
it would've been haunting the climb
without it I'm going to wait for it
but that's a second round that preview
should pull those that letter give them
pulls that lever not bossy so that no
one else could get up no that's just an
safety to get I said that that's my
thinking but no cigar
give me some more movement still Vince
this is holly dick chances are didn't
she swish me intelligent speciality yeah
they should put that as a personality
trait and complaining she's a major was
good with Y super complain [ __ ] there's
nothing to lose but I don't know if I
want to know what's gonna be up here
yes good all I did you know someone's
gonna jump in this test particles
manager I think it's no it's a place to
be yeah it doesn't look like your test
it's not stuff probably you know really
go to disk
funny you have you tried trying it on
convinced something I probably if ransom
why should you go what
you know where those do work it was not
indifferent to that it had that wails
and they fill up with it
it was young you don't know what was the
house then answer it was Authority and
I've you know I it was just a quick
press print up some protective sheet you
know this might be a generator yeah
what's in that room
you're next which is very tricky
sometimes knowing this is a look very
safe these tablets that box beside the
door thing out just a good iron yeah
I'm very unknown right now it just get
it so I get on the right day I could get
out fast idea in that music change music
this
I don't like the camera or an athlete
sub problem at all my show you dissing
or subject yes
yes
yeah that's speaks volume critic
oh it's a creepy expression to plot yet
Marshall
captain them yeah I think she should be
clear just controlling boys do it it
should be intelligent you summit this
you are so bad at this come on
that's the news
that's
besides way onto the one
data file instead he's also dead
yeah very much Jesus
see
it seems a bit strange I don't think so
I think that everybody would have died
if I [ __ ] that key - yeah but I didn't
I think she's gonna go getting so hot be
careful now he'll get me - Mitchell
but how did he get from right beneath
the mother realm like right now this is
not the time which one
concerned sarcastic
what don't move yeah I'm gonna try to
get you
just anybody couldn't show you a bunch
of divers on saying good job save Emily
oh [ __ ] jump o Saint oh I just wanna
sighs dang it does all of us is just
looking after himself
[ __ ] that was a big butterfly effect
right there sighing I don't know we
don't know yet something
okay I think that's alive don't know
about Emily we didn't see a dime we
didn't see I died regenerated wide shaft
again what in the hell this my Chuck is
so sick yeah but it's fine it's all
earrings got a melon
I think it's just one really big one and
this something really big going on is my
daughter she like I feel like she's
still alive
we've seen a diamond that would have
wanted to show us all enjoyed it which
one's shit-heap fill full and you know a
junk-food I think she's behind do you
reckon yeah I don't she's on the ground
but I think this is the only way I can
go is it okay I don't know why have to
go through the bond I think like I mean
I guess I can try it
now that's all of you have that one yeah
just based on that one time that we saw
I think she's probably been captured
Matt's [ __ ] dead what's so bad at
this [ __ ] oh my god